حذرت نائبه الامين العام للامم المتحده
مينا محمد عبر الجزيره اثناء جوله افريقيه
لها من تداعيات قرار موسكو تجميد العمل
باتفاق نقل الحبوب ويتزامن ذلك واتهامه
اوكراني لروسيا بمهاجمه
وهو ما نظرت به واشنطن وعواصم غربيه بين
مقاله موسكو ان تجميد الاتفاق اقتضاه
اخلال ببند رئيسي فيه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا كان ذلك خبر حلقتنا
ونناقشه في مسارات ثلاثه
منعكاسات ازمه تجميد اتفاق نقل الحبوب على
الامن الغذائي العالمي وبات داعياته على
المناطق الاكثر فقرا في العالم وما هي
الخيارات المطروحه على الدول التي راعت من
قبل ذلك الاتفاق وما الهدف الاستراتيجي
الروسي من قصف مستودعات الحبوب الاوكرانيه
في اوديسا بحسب مقاله اوكرانيا
كيف الامم المتحده ان تتعامل مع تداعيات
هذه الازمه وما هو افق التوصل لاتفاق جديد
في ضوء الشروط الروسيه
[موسيقى]
هيا بكل المقاييس ضربه قاسيه للامن
الغذائي العالمي ستكون لها دون شك
تداعيات بعدها قرار روسيا بتجميد العملي
باتفاق نقل الحبوب من البحر الاسود بررته
موسكو بعدم ادماج بنوك روسيه على صله
بالصفقه في نظام سويفت العالمي وكذلك عدم
السماح بتصدير الامونيا الروسيه اوكرانيا
شدت على لسان رئيسها ان القوات الروسيه
تعمدت مهاجمه منشات مدنيه بعضها معد
لتصدير الحبوب في اوديسا ما تسبب في اتلاف
ستين الف طن من هذه الحبوب القرار الروسي
اثار ردود فعل غربيه غاضبه وقال وزير
الخارجيه الامريكي ان الخطوه الروسيه غير
مقبوله وستتسبب في موجه غلاء اسعار وستجعل
وصول الغذاء للاكثر حاجه له للاكثر حاجه
له امرا اكثر صعوبه على نفس الوتيره
الخارجيتان الفرنسيه والاماء والالمانيه
ان روسيا تعرض الامن الغذائيه العالميه
للخطر بطريقه غير مسؤوله وفي الاثناء قال
الرئيس التركيه رجب طيب اردوغان انه قادر
على اقناع الرئيس بوتين بعوده روسيا الى
العمل باتفاق نقل الحبوب عبر البحر الاسود
وجدير بالذكر ان اوكرانيا تمثل عشره
بالمئه من سوق القمح العالميه وخمسه عشر
بالمئه من سوق الذره
و13% من سوق الشعير على مستوى العالم فضلا
عن زيوت الطعم
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم ولمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا كيف
قسطنطين شينكو وزير الخارجيه الاوكرانيه
السابق ومن موسكو
الاكاديميه والمحلله السياسيه ومن روما
الدكتور فاضل الزعبي الخبير في الامن
الغذائي بمركز جنيف للدراسات والممثل
السابق لمنظمه الفاو في منطقه الشرق
الاوسط وابدا بالسيد اولغا من موسكو يعني
العالم كله يتحدث عن ان القصف الروسيه
ليوديسا والانسحاب الروسيه او تجميد
مشاركه روسيا في اتفاق الحبوب هو طعنه
للفقراء الى اي متى تاخذ موسكو بعين
الاعتبار حاجه الفقراء في العالم الى
الحبوب الاوكرانيه
[موسيقى]
انا اعتقد ان هذا تفسير غير سليم لما حدث
في الواقع روسيا فعلا خرجت من اتفاقيه
الحبوب فقط لان
الواجبات التي التي كان من المفروض ان
تقوم بها الدول الغربيه اتجاه روسيا هذه
الواجبات لم تنفذ قد تكون روسيا مذنبه في
ان بعض الدول في اسيا او افريقيا سوف
تتعرض للجوع هذا تفسير غير سليم لان روسيا
تقوم بعروض انسانيه وتقديم الحبوب بالمجان
وايصالها لاي شعب من الشعوب المحتاجه لذلك
هذه الاتفاقيه اتفاقيه نقل الحبوب ليس لها
اي علاقه بما قد يحدث من جوع واتهام روسيا
هو شيء لا معنى له لان الاوضاع مختلفه في
الواقع
هذا هو راي روسيا فماذا عن الاوكرانيين
القسطنطين من كييف سيد قسطنطين لماذا
تعتقد اوكرانيا ان ما حدث في اوديسا وهو
قصف لمنشاه او منشاتين يمكن ان يسبب جوعا
في العالم
بغيت
الواضح جدا للعالم الان بان روسيا غير
مهتمه ولا تريد تقديم الطعام وسالم من
الغذاء والسلامه للعالم لو كانت بكل بساطه
فقط
توقف الاتفاق الخاص بنقل الحبوب
من الموانع الاوكرانيه
فان ذلك بحد ذاته يمكن يعتبر جريمه كبيره
ضد الانسانيه ولكن بعد ذلك فورا بعد هذا
قالوا بقصف المنشات
الميناء
والمعدات اللازمه لتحميل
المواد الغذائيه او الحبوب على السفن
وبالتالي اصبح من غير ممكن استخدام هذه
الموانئ لفتره طويله بعد ان
بعد تدميرا بحد كبير هذا ي بين ان تحديد
قدراته اوكرانيا على دعم احتياجات الدول
الاكثر فقرا في العالم الذين يحتاجون
المزيد من
الحبوب ولا ولا يهتمون ما تبقوا ولا وان
روسيا لم تبين اي ميل لديها لمساعده الدول
محتاجه والفقيره
من روما الدكتور فاضل
الزعبي وهو خبير امن غذائي وعمل مع منظمه
الفاو في الشرق الاوسط كان ممثل لا دكتور
دكتور فاضل نحن في حاله حرب
وهنالك كثير من المبالغات في الحروب كما
هو معروف مما استمعت اليه من الروايات
الغربيه والروايات الروسيه ما حقيقه الخطر
الذي يمس الامن الغذائي العالمي
مساء الخير شكرا الك هي طبعا بعيدا عن
تاسيس الموضوع والدفاع عن الموضوع وتوجيهه
بشكل سياسي نتحدث بشكل فني بحث
الامن الغذائي في العالم اساسا يعاني لا
تنسى ان الامن الغذائي في العالم كان
يعاني من جائحه كورونا ومن ثم التغيرات
المناخيه وثقل المديونيه على الدول ذات
الدخل المنخفض هذه كلها جاءت نقص الكميات
الغذاء سواء كانت قمح او الحبوب او البذور
الزيتيه جاءت لتساهم بارتفاع غير مسبوق في
عالم في عالم الغذاء وهذا الارتفاع طبعا
يؤثر بشكل مباشر على الدول ذات الدخل
المنخفض الان هذا كان في بدايه الحرب
وشاهدنا ارتفاعا غير معقول للاسعار اما
حاليا فان هذه الاتفاقيه وفرت ما يقارب
الثمانيه مليون طن من القمح على سبيل
المثال في سوق الغذاء العالمي اللي هو 200
مليون طن يعني تشكل 4% كانت قبل الحرب
تشكل 10% بس حتى الاربعه في المئه راح
رعب في اسعار الغذاء فالتاثير هو بشكل
اساسي على الارتفاع الاسعار ارتفاع
الاسعار نعم رح يجعل الدول ذات الدخل
المنخفض بنفس كميه المواد الاموال
المتوفره لها تحصل على غذاء اقل وبالتالي
سوف نشهد ارتفاع في نسبه انعدام الامن
الغذائي وانتشار نقص التغذيه خاصه دعني
اشير الى نقطه مهمه انه قبل اسبوعين صدر
التقرير السنوي الى منظمه الاغذيه
والزراعه مع اليونيسف والصحه العالميه
يعني الوضع الامن الغذائي في العالم اللي
اشار الا انه لاول سنه احنا ارقام عندنا
لم تزد ارقام انعدام الامن الغذائي لم تزد
بقيت كما هي وهذا يعتبر انجاز ان تبقى
بنفس المستوى الان مع هذا الوضع حتما
اضطراب الاسعار راح يؤدي الى خلل في سلاسل
التوريد وثقل على مديونيه الدول ذات الدخل
المنخفض اذن هنالك تاثير وان كنت ترى
دكتور فاضل انه تاثير محدود لكن دعنا
نتوجه ايضا الى ضيفتنا
يعني ربما يتفهم البعض الغضب الروسي من ما
تعتبره روسيا اخلالا ببنود في هذه
الاتفاقيه اتفاقيه تصدير الحبوب لكن ما
حاجه روسيا لقصف منشات خاصه بتخزين الحبوب
في بناء اوديسا ما هو الهدف من ذلك
ما كنت لاؤكد بشكل نهائي ان روسيا قصفت
الموانئ حيث تستودع وتخزن الحبوب هذه
اعلانات اوكرانيه يجب ان يتم التاكد منها
ولا ليس هناك مبدا في الثقه باوكرانيا نعم
قصفت روسيا اوديسا ولكن هذا كان ردا على
اعمال اوكرانيا عندما قامت بالهجوم على
جسر كرش القرمي وهذا هو الاطار الذي يجب
ان ننظر فيه على هذه الضربات لاوديسا لذلك
الحديث ليس عن محاوله روسيا ان تحرق
الحبوب الاوكرانيه كما تعلن اوكرانيا هذا
عن ذلك اتفاقيه الحبوب التي كانت
تسير خلال سنه
من هذه الحبوب كان من الذره اذا هذه ليست
حبوب عاديه ولذلك الحديث عن ان اوكرانيا
تنقذ العالم من الجوع ايضا شيء غير منطقي
روسيا لا تقصف تلك المناطق التي تتحدث
عنها اوكرانيا بل تقصف المستودعات
والمصانع حيث تصنع على اسلحه
وليس بهدف حرق الحبوب والتفسير الاوكراني
غير سليم طيب فيما يتعلق بالبنود وابقى
معك السيده فيما يتعلق بالبنود التي تقول
روسيا انه تم الاخلال بها ما هي هذه
البنود
وهل هي واضحه يعني مكتوبه متفق عليها بشكل
لا لبس فيه ام هي ايضا قراءه روسيه لهذه
الاتفاقيه
لم يتم الالتزام بها امام روسيا حسب
الاتفاق كان من المفروض ان يدمج البنك
المركزي الروسي للنظام البنكي العالمي
ولكن هذا ليس الشيء الاهم الاهم انهم
قاموا بمحاصره السماد الروسي بالعقوبات
ولم تستطع روسيا ان تقوم بتصدير السمادات
حسب الاتفاق اذا هذا الشرط لم ينفذ عدا عن
ذلك هناك ماده الامونيا التي تستخدم في
هذه السمادات وهناك خطوط نقل الامياك الذي
تم قصفها وكانت روسيا تعرضت لهذا الضرر
ولذلك لم يتم دمج البنك المركزي الروسي
ولم يسمح لنا بتصدير السماد
الروسي للاسواق العالميه عاده عن ذلك فجرت
خطوط الامونيا
وكل هذه الشروط تنقض الاتفاق اما اوكرانيا
كانت تتاجر بالحبوب بالذره
وبدلا من ان تقوم بمد العون للدول
الفقيره كانت تقوم بالمتاجره والمرابحه من
المتاجره مع دول اوروبيه اسمح لنا نشير
ايضا الى ما قاله الرئيس الروسي الذي
بوتين فضل استمرار تجميد ازمه تجميد اتفاق
الحبوب قال الرئيس الروسي ان الدول
الغربيه هي المسؤوله اما وصفه
بالتوقف او التشويه التام لاتفاق تصدير
الحبوب مع ذلك قال بوتين ان روسيا ستعود
لاتفاق تصدير الحبوب فورا اذا لبيت كل
شروطها للعوده وفي اخر التطورات وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه من جهه قالت ان موسكو
ستعتبر جميع السفن المبحره الى الموانئ
الاوكرانيه
ناقلات محت
لشحنات عسكريه اعود الى ضيفنا من السيد
ريشانكو وزير الخارجيه الاوكراني السابق
هذه الشروط الروسيه اليست شروطا معقوله هل
يعقل ان تصدر اوكرانيا الحبوب بضمانات
امنيه روسيه بينما هنالك قيود على روسيا
في كيفيه تحصيل ثمن حبوبها لانه بنك
الزراعات الروسي غير مدمج في نظام سويفت
العالمي وهنالك طرق ملتويه حتى تصل هذه
الاموال وايضا يقصف خط الامونيا الروسي
الذي كان يصدر منه الامونيا الروسي هل
يعقل ان تستمر هذه الاتفاقيه في ظل ما
يمكن وصفه بالاجحاف في حق موسكو هذين
الاجراءين
الاهم جزء فيما ما نواجههم المشكله حاليا
هو ان روسيا غزت اوكرانيا لو انها سحبت
قواته من اوكرانيا موجب اتفاقيه التي وقعت
منذ زمن بعيد لما شو واجهنا هذه المشكله
ناقشه الان سوى شيء ايجابي فقط ولكن بموجب
الظروف الحاليه من السخف حقا ان نعتقد ان
ان ان
مساله حاجه للاسمده
والامونية يمكن ان تمر بالطريق الذي يمر
به الساحات المعارك من السقف التوقع انه
يكون هذا المنبوب امنا لان هناك عمليات
عسكريه في تلك المنطقه التي يمر بها وما
هو مهم في رايه ان الجميع هنا يفهمون بان
هذا الاتفاق ما هي العمليه لفتره طويله
عذرا سيد ريشانكو ما هي العمليات العسكريه
التي عطلها خط الامونيا الروسي الذي يمر
باوكرانيا حتى يتم تفجيره لماذا تم تفجيره
الخط النقل هذه
ينتقل ينقل من روسيا الى اوكرانيا
وبالتالي هذا بالتاكيد امر في جبهات
القتال حيث هناك قتال يجري بين عسكريين
وبالتالي يمكن ان تتوقع ان يعمل هذا هذا
النظام او هذا الانبوب بشكل طبيعي فهذا
امر غير واقعي كيف يمكن ان
تقصف كيف والبنى المدنيه
ومناسبه
نحن لدينا كل اشرط فيديو التي تبين
تاثيرات
قصف
الموانئ والذي استخدمت تستخدم بشكل خاص
لتصدير
الحبوب من اوديسي جرى ذلك بشكل مقصود
ومحدد للتدمير هذه المنظومات وهذه المعدات
الخاصه بالتصدير هو اكثر من 60 الف طن من
الحبوب جرت تدميرها يوم امس وبالتالي
الاعتقاد حقا بان اي شخص يمكن ان يصدق مثل
هذا الانكار او هذا امر سخيف لاننا شاهدنا
نتائج القصف ويحصل في مكان اخرى روسيا
بشكل المقصود تقوم بتدمير
قدراته اوكرانيا
ذلك فقط
على فرص اخرى لروسيا التي تقدم نفسها
بطريقه ايجابيه ولكن ليس هناك من يصدقهم
ما هو مهم اليوم هو ان هو الموقف الموحد
المجتمع الدولي ينبغي لابد ان يؤدي الى
ايقاف ما تقوم به روسيا من عدوان وبعد ذلك
لها لا علاقه لنا ولا يكلف اكثر اي شيء
على ما تصدره اوكرانيا او روسيا من الحبوب
هذه المشكله اذا لم نحقق هذا فورا فعلينا
ان نعود الى الشروط والظروف التي قبلتها
والتي نجحت وعملت لفتره طويله هذه
الاولويه وبحصوص هذه الشروط يتوجه ايضا
الى ضيفنا من روما الدكتور فاضل الزعبي
هذه الشروط الروسيه مساله دمج البنك الخاص
بالصادرات الزراعيه الروسيه في نظام سوفت
العالمي
هل هذا يمكن تحقيق خصوصا في ضوء انتقالات
موسكو للامين العام للامم المتحده واخلاله
ببند مهم في هذه الاتفاقيه
خلينا بس نرجع للاتفاقيه الاتفاقيه تمت
بين الامم المتحده وتركيا وبين ومع روسيا
واوكرانيا كل على حذاء ما قامت به الامم
المتحده في الاتفاق مع روسيا لم يكن
التعهد برفع هذه هو التعهد على العمل لرفع
هذه القيود لسبب بسيط لانه من وضع هذه
القيود سواء قيود
الاسمده او التعامل المصرفي او التامين او
غيرها هي الدول الغربيه فليست الامم
المتحده وليست تركيا فلذلك هي لا تملك حق
ان تعطي الالتزام برفع هذه البنود بينما
العمل على ذلك وهي تعمل على ذلك منذ العام
تقريبا وتحاول واخر ما توصلت اليه كانت
موافقه البنك الاتحاد الاوروبي على ربط
البنك الزراعي الروسي من خلال شركه تتعامل
بالسويفت ثانيا خط نقل غاز الامونيا في
روسيا الى اوديسا في اوكرانيا ليصدر ثلاث
ملايين طن في العالم هذا الخط اساسا متوقف
عن العمل منذ بدايه الحرب هذا متوقف
فبالتالي ضرب او لم يضرب لا يؤثر على
تصدير هذه الغازات وايضا كيف سوف تقوم
الناقلات الخطره بحمل غاز الامونيا
بالدخول الى اوديسا
ونقل هذه المكونات الخطره
في منطقه تقريبا شبع حروف لذلك هذا الخط
هو اساسا معطل ولا يوجد اي شيء ومن بدايه
الحرب فلذلك يعني الشروط الروسيه تحاول
الان ان تبدا بالمطالبه بعشره حتى تحصل
على واحد حسب ما افهم والغرب الان ما هو
المنتظم
انا انا برايي الممكن وبكل بساطه العالم
يريد القمح سواء كان اوكرانيا او روسيا
لذلك انا عندما اتخلى عن السياسه
والتزم باخلاقي الانسانيه يجب ان اسمح
بوصول القمح
الروسي والاوكراني الى الجياع في العالم
اوكرانيا يتم عن طريق اعطاء الضمانات
روسيا يتم عن طريق ربط البنك الزراعي في
نظام سويفت وهذا ببساطه هذا المطلب يعني
يحقق اساسا ازدياد في الكميات وممكن ان
يخلق استقرار اكثر وهل هو سوق الغذاء
العالمي هل هذا المطلب ممكن ربط بنك
الصادرات الزراعيه الروسي بنظام سويفت
العالميه دون الحاجه الى وسائط هل هذا
ممكن تحقيقه
طبعا من الناحيه من الناحيه الماليه
والفنيه ممكن تحقيقه ولكن لكن المشكله اين
تكمن هل تريد هذه الدول ربط هذا البنك
ورفع هذه العقوبات هنا السؤال نعم السيده
اولغا ما هو التصور الروسي في ظل هذه
التعقيدات ما هو التصور الروسي
لان
لا يشوع احد في العالم بسبب انسحاب روسيا
من اتفاق او تجميد مشاركه روسيا في اتفاق
الحبوب ما هو المخرج من وجهه النظر
الروسيه لهذه الازمه سواء تم الاتفاق وتمت
اعاده روسيا للاتفاق ام لم تتم
موقف الرسمي الروسي
المعلن من قبل وزاره الخارجيه تعتمد على
ان روسيا مستعده كمساعده انسانيه دون اي
ثمن ان تقدم حبوبها للدول الفقيره في
افريقيا وفي اسيا هذا ما يمكن ان تقوم به
روسيا لاننا لدينا الكثير من الحبوب ونحن
اغنياء كمنتجين
للحبوب والظروف الطبيعيه تسمح لنا بهذا
وهذا كاثبات لحسن النوايا كشريك مسؤول
روسيا مستعده ان تقوم بهذا وهذا هو الموقف
الرسمي في روسيا وبهذه الطريقه من
المستحيل ان نتهم روسيا باي شيء فقط لمجرد
تجميدها
للاتفاق حتى تستمر اوكرانيا بتصدير حبوب
الذره روسيا ممكن ان تقدم الحبوب الغذائيه
للدول الفقيره لذلك روسيا
دورتها بالمجان لكن دكتور فاضل ما واقعيه
فكره عوده روسيا الى هذه الاتفاقيه واذا
لم تعد روسيا الى الاتفاقيه ما هي خيارات
العالم ما هي خيارات السوق
اتوقع اتوقع انه نوع من المفاوضات وهذا ما
يسعى اليه الجانبان اتوقع ان يتم العوده
الى هذا الاتفاق قد تكون ببعض الشروط
المعدله قد تكون ببعض الشروط مشروطه على
سبيل المثال يتم الاتفاق على رفع القيود
حول بنك الزراعي بحلول كذا وهكذا اتوقع
ذلك اما اذا ما استمر الاتفاق فسوف يكون
هنالك تاثير
محدود على وضع الامن الغذائي في العالم
ولا تنسى ان العالم مع اخره الصدمه الاولى
في بدايه الحرب الكثير من الدول اخذت
اجراءات احتياطيه وزادت مخزونات
الاستراتيجيه
الغرب ايضا يجب ان يقوم بواجبه على سبيل
المثال من اجل ايقاف اعباء الديون للدول
المتوسطه الدخل شكرا جزيلا لك دكتور فاضل
الزعبي الخبير في الامن الغذائي بمركز
جنيف دراسات والممثل السابق لمنظمه الفاو
في الشرق الاوسط ونشكر ضيفنا بالكيف
كونستانتين غريشينكو وزير الخارجيه
الاوكرانيه السابق ومن موسكو اولغا كرايس
الاكاديميه والمحلله السياسيه في
الجامعه الوطنيه شكرا لكم جميعا وبهذا نصل
لختام هذه الحلقه من برنامج مهراء الخبر
في امان الله
[موسيقى]